PROFESSOR: Another
basic proof technique
is called Proof By Cases,
which we prove something
by breaking it up into
pieces that are easy to prove
but that together cover
all possibilities.
Let's look at an
explicit, simple example
from computer science.
Here's a Java
logical expression.
The way to decipher this is
that the double vertical bar
means "or" in Java.
And the double ampersand
means "and" in Java.
So this is a conditional
test, an IF test,
that is the guard
on a bunch code
to be executed if this
test comes out to be true.
Let's read the test.
If x is greater than 0, or x
is less than or equal to 0,
and y is greater
than 100, go ahead
and do the code that's in there
indicated by the vertical dots.
We're going to assume here
that x and y are variables that
are declared to be of
type floating point,
[? or a ?] real number, or
integers for that matter.
OK.
Now what I claim is this
code can be improved if it's
rewritten in the following way.
Namely, if x is greater than
0 or y is greater than 100.
So the claim is that these
two hunks of codie, if I just
replace this test, which has
three components that require
an extra step to
evaluate some cases,
by this code the
programs are going
to behave exactly the same way.
And therefore it's just
more efficient and easier
to understand.
One is one step faster if I
replace this longer expression
by this shorter expression.
Now how do I argue that
these two pieces of code
are going to behave in
exactly the same way,
or come up with the
same final output?
They won't behave
exactly the same
because one will be
faster than the other.
But they're going to
yield the same results.
OK, let's consider how these
two behave in two cases.
The first case will be that the
number x really is positive,
that it's greater than 0.
What happens then?
Well, the first test above in
the "or" comes out to be true.
And that means that the whole
"or" expression is true.
Because when you have a true
"or" anything at all, it
comes out to be true.
And you go ahead and
execute code that follows.
Likewise, the second
expression starts
with x greater than 0 "or."
So it comes out to be true.
So, in this case, if
x is greater than 0,
both conditional
expressions will
allow the code that follows
them to be executed.
Because they both
evaluate to true.
OK.
The next case is that x
is less or equal to 0.
Let's see what happens then.
Well, in the top
expression, since x
is less than or equal to
0, that first expression,
x greater than 0, if
evaluated, returns false.
And same thing in the
second expression.
The initial test x greater
than 0 returns false.
Now one of the things
that the ways "or" works
is that if you have an
"or" of a bunch of things,
if the first thing is
false, you ignore it
and just proceed
to the other things
to see how they come out.
So what that means
is that in both
of these expressions, since
the first test in the sequence
of things that are being "ored"
together came out to be false,
I can just ignore them.
The code is going to behave
as though, after the false was
detected, it's just going
to behave in the same way
that the rest of the
test says to behave.
Well, in the top case,
the expression to be check
now is that x is less
than or equal to 0,
and y is greater than 100.
But what do we know?
Well, x less than or
equal to 0 in this case.
So this test comes
out to be true.
And we have something
of the form true "and"
something or other.
That means that the net
outcome of this expression, it
depends entirely on
the something or other.
That is, it depends entirely
on whether y is greater than 0.
Because the x is less
than or equal to 0.
And so this expression
can be simplified.
It's going to behave
exactly according to whether
or not y is greater than 100.
So look what I've just done.
I've argued that
in this case, both
of these tests cards act like y
is the test y greater than 100.
Which is, they behave the
same in this case as well.
So what I just figured out
was that, in both cases,
these two expressions
yield the same result.
And the only possible cases
are that x is greater than 0,
or x is less than or equal to 0.
So in all cases, they're
the same, and we're done.
That's why it's safe to
replace the upper complicated
expression by the lower,
less complicated expression.
So, in general as I
said, reasoning by cases
breaks complicated problems
into easier sub problems.
Which is what we just saw there.
[? It ?] wouldn't be clear
how to prove that these two
things were equivalent,
but I chose those cases
and it made each case easy
to figure out that the two
things with the same.
Now, the truth is that there
are some philosophers who
worry about reasoning by cases
for kind of subtle reasons.
They're called intuitionists.
And here's what bothers them.
Let me illustrate it.
There's a million dollar
Clay Institute question.
One of the dozen or
so questions that
are considered to be
the major open problems
in various disciplines
of mathematics.
And one of the
disciplines of mathematics
is complexity theory
in computer science,
computational complexity theory.
This question is known as
the p equals np question.
And we're actually going to talk
about it a fair amount in just
the coming few lectures.
But for now, it doesn't
matter what it means.
Well, I'll tell
you what it means.
p stands for
polynomial time, and np
stands for nondeterministic
polynomial time.
I'm not going to define not
deterministic polynomial time,
but it would be momentous if
those two things were equal.
And everyone expects
that they're not equal,
but no one knows
how to prove that.
So the million dollar
question is, is p equal to np,
yes or no?
And you get a million dollars
for settling this question.
Now, I claim that in fact
the answer to this question
is on my lecture table.
And I will show it to
you in class tomorrow.